the morning's work done obsessive
cleaner Rene has finished clearing up
his workstation but he won't muck in to
help others team working that I don't
really work like that
use something wash it up simple in it
we've introduced easier Rene's I'm
alright Jack attitude is making G's job
impossible this is a kitchen it's a team
it has stuff to be doing everyone needs
to chip him and it was done really well
with it apart from any who will sit on
his work surface like that until we go
and I've tried I've approached him and
said you know can you help out no miss
like yeah but I've done my staff and
everyone interferes and then it just all
escalated and I said what you want
brownie points for every ball you wash
up Rennie is kicked off with G
[Music]
I'm quite a ballsy female so having a
man yell at me but yeah this is Smith
could you just grab a towel I could all
[ __ ] again on my return to the prison
I'm shocked to hear what Rennie has done
if that guy can't this far down the line
please head down and become a team
player than no chance I warned the team
the next person to walk out would stay
out thank you
Reni knows the rules the I wasn't I
heard what happened
she wasn't exaggerating come on
wish he said like John a Blue Peter by
draw brownie or something hit my button
if I said to do something can it eat
your button you're gonna try and hit me
back with a word and that's how you know
I'm not gonna do that [ __ ] that I want
you to drop the sensitivity that sort
yeah I don't know see I'm wrong sorry
supposing a situation like that happens
outside of here one but how do you know
what I've got faith that one listen keep
your head down
Thanks Reni is heading back to his cell
[Music]
from my original 12 I'm down to just
nine men again this time for good
about Friday we can't tolerate that
Ronnie's definitely coming back okay
yeah do you know the biggest upset with
Rene the guy was a kook I mean he could
tight hold his own in the kitchen but
couldn't talk to anybody and you know
you're not gonna stand alone you need
help
what does it say last week the week are
gonna fall the wayside strong gets
stronger
while I've still got the bones of my
team I'm desperate to start full-time
lunch deliveries but it will need a huge
commitment from the prison authorities
to let my workforce out of their cells
the necessary 6:00 a.m. start in order
to run a lunch delivery service you'd
have to have the ability to get
prisoners working from very early on in
the morning which means we'd have to
have staff on in order to make that
happen
we know when you're paying someone to
cut sandwiches and a salmon shop
normally outside papers I'm to guard
them while doing it
and it may well be that you would have
an operation employing say six to ten
people which have might have a
disproportionate effect on the way we're
running the whole jail this is a huge
blow the prison are unable to supply the
early morning security I need to go into
full-time lunch production without this
product the bad boys bakery is not in
business the guys would have to be in
here at the crack of dawn you know five
six o'clock in the morning and when you
have got access to those prisoners until
9:00 show that have them disappear for
this hour or another there's just no way
no that's never gonna work we go and I
think again come up with something I can
cook on the inside 9:00 to 5:00 complete
in here and said